مدفعيه ودبابات ومسيرات لم تكن وقودا
كافيا لاشعال الوضع في الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا تلويح ومخاوف من استخدام السلاح
النووي سيطرت على اجواء الحرب تبعتها
اتهامات المتبادله بين الطرفين باستخدام
القنبله القذره ثم كانت المسيارات
الايرانيه التي خدمت القوات الروسيه فيها
هجماتها على اوكرانيا والان يلقى الحديث
الى اسلحه محرمه دوليا
في ظل الخسائر والتراجع الروسي في
اوكرانيا تتوقع الولايات المتحده ان تلجا
موسكو الى الاسلحه الكيماويه اذا استمر
تراجعها بحسب مجله بوليتكو والتي نسبت
المعلومات الى مسؤولين امريكيين
مقابل الشكوك الامريكيه جددت موسكوتها
مكيف باجراء تجارب بيولوجيه عسكريه تحت
اشراف امريكيه مؤكده انها ستقدم تفاصيل
تلك التجارب التي اعلنت عنها في مارس
الماضي بالرغم من نفي واشنطن وكيف
[موسيقى]
شتاء طويل سمر على طرفي الحرب ليصبح تقدم
الاسلحه التقليديه على الارض صعبا ويفتح
احتمال تحولها الى حرب غير تقليديه قد
يتجاوز اثرها وكوارثها حدود البلدين اذا
عمر العربيه